OK.
So things are not moving as quickly as we
would like to see, but things are happening
in terms of corona virus treatment.
So I want to update that now.
Over time, there is going to be so much more
happening that I can't realistically in one
video squeeze everything in.
So what I'll do is I'll quickly update you
on what we've had up until now and then I'll
get to the new stuff.
So coronavirus being a virus, not a bacteria.
We're looking at vaccines, antivirals and
antibody treatments, not antibiotics.
There are now vaccines entering stage one
clinical trials on humans.
First step is make sure that the vaccine is
remotely safe, not causing terrible side effects.
Then you start following volunteers with different
doses, usually over a year, see what's the
effective dose, antibody generation, etc.
We're in that process.
Number two, antivirals.
I already told you about REM Desert Vier and
Afghan.
These are being tested on small groups of
patients.
Both have significant side effects and only
possible efficacy anecdotal evidence so far.
We need the results of the trials that are
ongoing.
And then lastly, on Monday I told you about
some antibody treatments.
Multiple labs and researchers exploring antibody
transfusions from patients who have recovered.
That's pretty inefficient right now.
You need antibodies from one recovered patient
can be used on one sick patient with risks.
So that's just an idea right now.
That's what we covered Monday.
Let's now get to the new stuff.
Chloroquine is being tested.
Chloroquine may be better pron..
Chloroquine is a malaria prophylactic and
treatment.
It's not new.
Chloroquine has been around since 1934.
It's available generic.
It's cheap.
We're talking pennies to a few dollars per
dose.
There are already some papers on this, including
one called Expert Consensus on Chloroquine
Phosphate for the treatment of novel coronavirus.
Pneumonia.
Elon Musk recently tweeted about chloroquine,
I believe he was given chloroquine when he
actually had malaria.
If I recall correctly, got people paying more
attention to it.
What does the study say?
The study says that so far, quote, We found
that treating the patients diagnosed as novel
coronavirus pneumonia with chloroquine might
improve the success of treatment.
Shorten Hospital Stay and improve patient
outcome.
This is early research.
It's up in the air.
We also heard from French research Professor
DDA Rao, who said that the first cobia 19
patients he treated with chloroquine saw a
rapid and effective speeding up of their healing
process.
A decrease of how long they remained contagious.
That's good news.
We need more testing.
All right.
He said we were able to ascertain patients
who had not received the drug containing chloroquine.
We're still contagious after six days.
But of those that got chloroquine, only 25
percent were still contagious.
Small sample, but that's good.
We also have a new U.S. academic study that
says the same.
It's a study called An Effective Treatment
for Coronavirus.
It's by Todaro and regard no, which says the
use of chloroquine is showing favorable outcomes
in humans infected with coronavirus, including
faster time to recovery and a shorter hospital
stay promising need to keep researching.
Then we've got a lot of noise about Interfer
on Alpha to be a bunch of articles from Cuban
media claiming that this is a cure.
We don't know yet.
There is hope that this anti-viral interferon
alpha 2B could help.
It has helped with viruses similar to Kove
19.
We just don't know yet.
And the idea is, again, use these medications
to prevent cases from getting as serious.
And then lastly, there is the idea of using
two drugs lapine there and written there in
conjunction with chloroquine or not.
And there are studies which show that in vitro
Lapine, Vier and Raton of their sometimes
combined with chloroquine can work against
viruses like Corona virus.
Again, this is in vitro.
We have no clinical studies on patients.
So it's early.
Like I said, keep isolating.
It's not fun.
It's boring for a lot of people.
I want to go out, see my friends, hang out
at cafes, not worry at the grocery store.
I get it.
But we've got to work together to save lives
and reduce transmission until we make progress.
Things are happening.
There are a lot of things in the hopper sort,
so to speak.
We have to let the doctors and the scientists
do their thing.
In the meantime, don't fall for any scam cures.
And I'll talk more about that later on in
the program.